ahora quiero demostrar una forma de
construir una onda seno lo que vamos a
hacer es construir algo que parezca seno
de omega t aquí tenemos nuestra función
del tiempo
y aquí en nuestra frecuencia
esta animación nos va a ayudar a
construir nuestra ondas en esta línea
verde es un vector en rotación y digamos
que el radio de este círculo es uno aquí
tenemos un vector que está rotando
lentamente
y la línea punteada de aquí y este punto
amarillo que sube y baja esta es la
proyección de la punta de nuestro vector
verde en el eje y
conforme el vector está girando podemos
ver que la proyección en el eje y va
hacia arriba hacia abajo y de nuevo
hacia arriba y hacia abajo y esto lo
hace en un patrón senoidal ahora vamos a
poner otra animación en donde veremos
qué hace este punto amarillo conforme
pasa el tiempo
esta es nuestra gráfica así luce la onda
seno vean que cuando la línea verde
llega a 0 aquí vamos a esperar que
llegue a este punto el valor de la línea
amarilla cuando pasa por 0 es igual a 0
así que esta línea amarilla es una
gráfica del seno de omega t
esta proyección es sobre el eje y vamos
a hacer la misma animación pero ahora
con la proyección sobre el eje x y esto
nos va a producir una onda coseno veamos
como luce
en este caso ya cambiamos nuestra
animación y podemos ver que la
proyección está sobre el eje x aquí está
mi punto amarillo y esto me produce una
onda coseno esto es coseno de omega t
y como estamos rastreando el progreso en
el eje x la onda coseno da la impresión
de estar emergiendo hacia abajo así que
el eje del tiempo está aquí abajo
cuando nuestra flecha verde llega a cero
aquí el valor del coche no es 1 y cuando
es de menos 180 grados el coche no vale
menos 1 y es por eso que esta es una
onda coseno y tiene la misma frecuencia
que la onda seno que vimos anteriormente
y ahora quiero mostrarles ambas
animaciones al mismo tiempo ya que es
algo bastante bonito
y aquí voy a dejar esta animación por un
momento
y verán que nuestra onda seno se genera
en color amarillo
y veremos en anaranjado a nuestra onda
coseno siendo generada y ambas vienen de
este vector verde que está rotando
esta es una demostración muy sencilla de
cómo generar senos y cosenos con la idea
de un vector rotacional y podemos
generar este vector rotacional usando
algunas ideas de la aritmética compleja
y la fórmula de hoy leer
yo encuentro este patrón realmente
hermoso y más porque surge de una idea
bastante simple de un vector en rotación